this was the scene on board united
airlines flight 328
shortly after takeoff from denver
international airport
troy lewis had just closed his eyes for
a nap when he heard
a loud bang knew that that was not good
and felt like it was on our side of the
plane and i was over the wing and i
flipped up the shade and saw the
front of that engine missing or blown up
and the
smoke and pieces were flying off of it
and that
was not a good feeling and this is how
it looked from the ground
one of the boeing 777s two engines
suffered catastrophic failure
debris rained down on residential
neighborhoods about 40 kilometers north
of the airport
i could definitely see things flying at
me and
yeah my daughter was sitting on the
window and she's a you know i was just
like don't look like let's let's close
it up and
let's just pray so that's what we did we
kind of just held hands and said some
prayers
the carrier says 231 passengers and 10
crew members were on board
the flight which was headed for hawaii
returned to denver
and landed safely to the cheers of
passengers
emergency crews were there to greet them
but thankfully no one was hurt
i'm happy to be down down here alive so
it's just like anything count your
blessings
statistically engine failure is rare but
pilots
are trained to fly with just one engine
the national transportation safety board
and federal aviation administration
are investigating what caused the
incident they've asked residents to
report
but not touch any debris they find
kristin salumi al jazeera
u.s president joe biden has approved a
major disaster declaration for texas
freeing up emergency federal funds after
the state's deadly winter freeze
millions of people have had to deal with
days of power and water cuts
after a massive snow storm overwhelmed
utility companies
power plants are now back online but
blackouts persist and many people
are still having to boil their drinking
water